Thank You Adam and thank you all for
joining us here today is really a
distinguished panel to discuss a topic
that to me at least sounds very dramatic
the future of truth i I didn't expect us
to talk about an issue like that just a
couple of years ago and I don't think
anyone here expected us to talk about it
so so why not just start by by asking
you all and walk through the panel how
how worried should we be about this
question professor - if you like to talk
announcer is very easy very worried and
it's the urge to muddle the mud orders
the money the truth for your own reasons
whether it's incumbent industries are
being threatened because it makes you
feel uncomfortable the fact that people
will say well if you accept this then
there might be government regulation
that will control your life tell you
something you don't want to do and it
will take your livelihood away so the
combination of having the reassuring lie
and the threat that the truth may
actually affect you in a way that you
don't want to be affected is very
beguiling
Maggie Haberman I think the New York
Times has used the truth as in its
marketing you stand for the truth is
hard that's I think part of our slogan
and that's certainly true but I mean the
truth is no longer an agreed-upon set of
facts which i think is the challenge
that we are dealing with and we have a
we have many people and critics who are
trying to erode faith and the facts but
none are more prominent than the
president the United States who has
appropriated the term fake news in a way
that we've never seen before
- unfazed and his definition as any
story he doesn't like and he terms that
as something that is therefore not real
um in in addition to what the professor
was saying I think the the key in terms
of the future of truth is there is one
of the one of the forms of politics that
are the u.s. president was elected
through
was this paranoid style which has been
written about repeatedly but most
impressively in the 1960s and there's
this idea that there's a hidden hand at
work that there everything is sort of
part of a larger conspiracy and this
president is able to channel that in
ways that I've really never seen before
and that concerns me more than anything
because no matter what we write as I
discovered during the campaign people
just wouldn't believe it we're seeing it
right now with a Senate race in Alabama
in the United States where there's a
candidate who Republican candidate who
was accused by a number of different
women of sexual and proprieties and
sexual misconduct and voters in a focus
group that aired last night believed
that these women were paid to lie
because that's what they were told you
know this person can't do anything wrong
I don't know how we get around that but
our politics certainly in the United
States are so tribal right now that it's
very difficult general Hayden how
worried are you so you've got several
layers of effects
the first one mentioned is it just
Muddy's of the water and it prevents us
from arriving at long-term solutions
you've got this conspiracy theory
blending just below the surface in
American political life I've got an
effect it's a second or third order
effect or what I would call in my my
military life additional collateral
damage and and and that's on the
institutions that we normally turn to to
provide us truth it's the five I put up
their intelligence science scholarship
journalism in the courts and the
president has mounted such an assault on
them as to undermine their legitimacy as
Maggie just said in the American
dialogue but there's an additional turn
of the wheel they're all fighting back
the sound you hear from Washington is
institutional America pushing back on
the narrative of the president and
includes the National Football League in
the Boy Scouts all right I mean
everyone's pushing back but there's a
danger all right there's a danger that
these institutions these professions
will over achieve in the pushing back so
Maggie has to be very careful that she
remains the Free Press and doesn't
become the opposition or the resistance
my tribe
has to remain professional and not push
back by saying things publicly despite
the circumstances at the moment should
not be said publicly we should not leak
and so I greatly fear that good
institutions in self-defense will do
themselves long-term harm in responding
to these assaults but in in order to to
address this problem we really need to
understand how we could or how we ended
up in it so you mentioned the race in
Alabama and and Roy Moore so how should
we outside the u.s. understand that a
candidate which such in history and with
all the accusations that are there and
then the women who talks about him but
people don't care about it I mean I
think that some people care about it but
not that what we discovered I would
trace it back certainly in the in the
area of the me2 movement which we are
seeing all over the globe and this would
apply in the Roy Moore Senate race I
would trace it back in the u.s. to what
happened in the presidential election
when this now-infamous Access Hollywood
tape was released which was a decade old
tape of President Trump saying a phrase
about grabbing women's genitals which
I'm not going to repeat but I suspect
most of you know and the person who
conducted the interview Billy Bush was
fired and the person who gave the
interview Donald Trump was elected
president and the message that women I
think across the world but certainly in
the United States many women took from
that was there are no consequences for
that type of behavior that type of
language toward women
and I think women got very upset but
what Donald Trump proved is that if you
wait it out if you refuse to be thrown
out of the ring of politics if you do
not give in and do adhere to the norms
that we have seen before which is with
that kind of a scandal you step out of
the race or you apologize or you
apologize every day thereafter if you
just don't do any of that you can
actually withstand the hurricane and
that is what Roy Moore is attempting the
more might not win but at the the
betting is that he will but twenty years
ago people would have cared more about a
candidate like that and and his
behavioural professor chiu well is there
a change here there is a change but if
you look back at how the yeah states was
founded visionaries what did they say
they said in order to have a working
democracy you need two things you need
education an educated public therefore
public education was a very big deal and
you need a free press and so what is our
current president doing he's attacking
both with consistency and sometimes the
president says we've run the story
that's it we don't have to do it again
the president says he says that over and
over and over again so many times that
the repeated lie becomes confused with
the truth now in the tax bill they want
to tax American university endowments
they want to say that graduate students
which have a tuition waiver should be
taxable income so it's a very very
complete assault on the two bastions
that feedback to gives America American
democracy stability so what will be the
consequences for universities in America
of this that you talk about now changes
in tax system and endowments well we'll
see if it happens this is being quote
reconciled between House and Senate
versions but again just as the press and
the intelligence community have to
always be seen as neutral advocates for
what we know to the best of our
knowledge to be correct today and it
gets refined tomorrow and so this is
what we have to do we can't stoop to
this other level and as David Gross said
you know it is tough when the liars are
played by different rules but you've
been you're a scientist but you've also
been in politics you've been part of the
government and these are different
logics how are these two system operates
right how should a scientific community
defend itself against politicians who
act this way
they have to just say patiently that
this is what we know and repeat that the
other thing I should say is that science
and technology have the opportunity to
give better choices and so there will be
perhaps 40% of the American public will
never be convinced that if the climate
is changing that's due to humans okay
just as some reasonable equivalent
fraction will never be convinced that
evolution is just another theory and so
instead you give them you don't want
this new way of sustainable energy clean
energy is actually going to be lower
cost you mentioned the word patience my
general Hayden is that it's patience
enough no it's necessary but not
sufficient I mean you've got it you've
got to take advantage of the space that
patience courage so what what I
generally tell folks in my profession is
do your duty the nation depends on you
all right
protect yourself and that's not
something I would normally say protect
your institution which is really
important back to the earlier point
about when we write the history of this
institutions like American intelligence
have to get a grade better than a
gentleman see they have to be viewed as
having in their own ways even behind
closed doors having stood up and and
pushed back against this and then
finally I'd add one additional thing we
make a lot in a in America about the
what what I've learned to call the
benign hunter okay which is the military
officers that the president has brought
in around him and most Americans take
take that as a good thing because they
kind of create guardrails and buffers
and may not be as bad as it might have
been without these folks here there will
come a point though at which these men
all of them I know and admire are going
to have to decide whether or not they've
ceased being adequate guardrails and
bumpers and they have become enablers
and legitimize errs and may have to take
a dramatic step one of the things that
happens and I'm sorry to interject but
you just hit on a preschool one of the
things that happens with people who are
around Donald Trump and this has
happened for years but never with such
high stakes as we see now is that people
you know because he presents such an
unreality bubble for people who come
near him people have one of two choices
either reject that unreality bubble and
go to a different form of reality that
they know and that other people can
agree with or they take on his sense of
grievance his sense of paranoia his
sense of being under threat the number
of people around him including from with
the generals describing as the benign
Hunta which some people are describing
us you know the cast of seven days in
May is another example but but what what
you see with some of them without
getting specific is certain members are
taking on of his team who have military
experience are taking on some of his
particular grievances they are starting
to adopt them themselves they're
starting to take on aspects of his
viewpoint if not the entirety of it and
that goes to the same point that you're
saying that is how you stop that is how
you stop seeing you know the car coming
at you and and learn to jump out of the
way do that's not tactical reasons or do
they actually believe in the things that
they are saying I don't think it's
tactical I think it might start out as
tactical but for to the professor's
point about the repetition of something
I mean repetition was key in Trump's
campaign in 2016 if you say something
over and over again somebody starts to
absorb it but Professor - but the other
thing to realize is when you're in the
public limelight when you're in public
well government I was about to say
public service that you can be attacked
and and some of it is untrue and even if
it's only five percent of the time
you're being attacked it's completely
untrue you begin to react and I think
that you have to not let that get into
your skin and you have to do continue to
do what's right and luckily since I
never wanted a career in politics that
was easy
make my day you can fire me
I mean people who work for the president
how should they think about this if they
feel that they're doing more harm
actually by leaving the system then
still being there and trying to protect
the institutions it's a great question
and and when I just blurted it out maybe
at some point you have to know you're
not a bumper or gardener anymore you're
an enabler you're legitimize er you
should go and then the next question
that comes to my mind is and then what
happens where do you do and when it's
clear and where do you draw the line
well I mean that's that's a personal
choice and Maggie's already suggested
that there are folks looking at this
from the outside who are seeing things
they would not have expected yes I mean
I think look I don't know I think I
think we're going to find out in the
coming months as you start to see a lot
of people leave the Trump administration
and I do think you're going to see many
Dena Powell one of his national security
advisors yesterday now she was leaving I
think you are going to see other
departures and then I think you are
going to find out where people's
personal red lines are but I do think
that you raise the key question of this
administration which I've heard from
every single person in the White House
many of whom speak to reporters out of
trying to get some kind of just a sense
it's like therapy for them because they
feel so disconnected from a sense of
objective reality as I said this
unreality bubble the president creates
is distorted for people around him but I
think you are going to find out what
that red line is but I do think there is
a point that for having people there in
many instances it is better than not
they only they can decide how much they
can take on this maybe not
optimistic but the realistic note we
thank you all for joining us here today
and sharing your views thank you very
much indeed
[Applause]
[Music]